This video is brought to you by blinkers.
The first 100 people to go to blinkist.com forward slash biographics.
We'll got one week to try it out.
You'll also get 25% off if you won the full membership, which you probably will,
and let's get into it.
Is.
Dawn of the 14th century. I mean, not right now, but in our story,
the kingdom of Scotland is in chaos over a dozen Nobles have made a claim for
the throne threatening to plunge the country into civil war. Meanwhile,
the King of England is making a play for control of his Northern neighbor,
hoping to take advantage of the power vacuum,
to unify all of great Britain under a single roulette. But as son Sue said,
in the midst of chaos, there is also opportunity Robert,
the Bruce member of a Scottish Nobel family certainly took this to heart,
using a mix of doggy determination, tactical acumen, and political savvy.
The reus fought off all internal rivals and then made war on England,
throwing the English out of the country and establishing himself as the one true
ruler of Scotland. By doing this,
he not only became the most important King in the history of Scotland,
but his actions had far reaching consequences that continue to be felt to this
very day.
[Inaudible].
I was born in July, the 11th, 1274, the eldest son of Robert to Bruce,
the Lord of Annandale,
the powerful noble in the kingdom of Scotland literally is recorded of his early
life that we can assume he was brought up in much the same way.
As most Nobles of the period were educated in multiple languages,
via arts and skills of war and the politics and customs of the raw course in
1286, the King of Scots Alexander,
the third died suddenly after falling off his horse,
his only living descendant was a young granddaughter Margaret who was the
daughter of the King of Norway as was customary.
When a child ascended to the throne,
a council of regions called the guardians of Scotland were appointed to govern
the country until Margaret was old enough to rule by herself.
But it wasn't a me Margaret died in 1290 at the age of seven,
never having set foot in the kingdom that she was supposed to rule. Now,
the guardians were faced with a huge problem.
The 250 year long reign of the house of Dunkeld had ended with the death of
Alexandra Margarets and a new Monarch needed to be crowns.
But who I told you a of 13 Nobles made claims on the throne of Scotland,
one of which was Robert Bruce.
The guardians were afraid that any attempt to resolve the matter internally
would lead to civil war. So they asked King Edward,
the first of England do arbitrary in the dispute,
Edwards known as long shanks because at six foot two,
he towered over most men of his day was eager to take advantage of the chaotic
situation for his own ends. Before agreeing to the arbitration,
he forced the guardians to make concessions to him stopping just short of
declaring Scotland, a planned state over lauded by King Edward, Edward,
then set up a quarter of 104 auditors' to decide who should be declared King of
the Scots. The process that was known as the great cause for two years,
the court heard arguments from various claimants.
The court decided in favor of John Balliol, thought of Galway in 1292,
but the real winner had been Edward.
[Inaudible].
Four years. Edward continue to assert pressure on Scotland,
forcing further concessions and relations between Edward and John Valley.
All soon began to deteriorate the Bruces.
At this time sided with Edward in the disputes,
they hated barley and considered him a usurper this put them into conflict,
but the come in clan staunch supporters of Bally.
Oland's one of the most powerful families in the country. In 1296,
the Bruces were living in Carlisle castle and English Fords that had been given
to them by King Edwards.
After being driven out of Scotland by the Cummins in March of 1296,
color was attacked by members of the coming faction,
who hopes to eliminate their rivals, the attack failed.
But the incursion onto English soil gave Edward an excuse to invade Scotland and
take over the whole country. Personally,
he deposed John Balliol and imprisoned him in the tower of London.
Edward believed that Scotland had been pacified and he returned South to deal
with the French, but the trouble in the North,
it was only really just beginning in may, 1297,
a rebellion against English control of Scotland began led by William Wallace and
Andrew Demaret Roberts ordered by Edward to go with his retainers and suppress
the rebellion, had a change of heart on routes. And when he arrived,
he decided to join with the Scots all as in Demari,
won a great victory over the English at the battle of Stirling bridge in July.
But the Bruce, along with most of the other Nobles, they went there instead.
They were engaged in intense negotiations with King Edward William Wallace fell
from grace after he was defeated by Edward at the battle of Falco and
July, 1298. And in his place, two new guardians of Scotland were appointed.
Robert, the Bruce and John Cannon of Baton Ark.
This attempt at national unity backfired as the two men were mortal enemies.
And couldn't agree on anything early in 1302, Robert switched sides again,
and swore loyalty to King Edwards. It's likely he did this for two reasons.
The Nobles in Scotland were increasingly coalescing around the idea of John
Balliol being returned to the throne. And if that happens,
Robert would lose his chance to wear the crown himself. Also,
it looked as though Edward was winning the war and Robert believed the smart
play was to bide his time.
Perhaps even wait until the 60 three-year-old Edward died before making his
move.
[Inaudible].
The Bruce was now playing a very delicate game outwardly. He supported Edwards,
hold on Scotland behind the scenes. However,
he was rallying support for his own bid for the throne of Scotland,
a significant obstacle presented itself in the form of John Cummin.
Robert's rival considered the most powerful noble in the country in the summer
of 1305, shortly after the capture and execution of William Wallace.
The Bruce made a deal with coming that come in,
would renounce his claim to the throne in exchange for all of the Bruce land in
Scotland. If he supported a revolt led by the Bruce,
but sometime later coming betrayed the Bruce's intentions to King Edwards and
Robert was forced to flee the English course to avoid arrest outraged.
Robert set a meeting with come in at the grey FRAs monastery in Dumfries on
February the 10th, 1306 during the meeting,
the Bruce accused Kevin of treachery and the two men actually came to blows in a
fit of rage.
Robert drew his dagger and stabbed coming as retain is then rushed in and killed
the man immediately. Robert realized the gravity of what had done.
He had shed blood in a church.
The ultimate sacrilege furthermore had killed one of the most powerful men in
Britain guaranteeing the animosity of Cummins allies and relatives on both sides
of the border. The die had been cost.
He needed to make his play for the throne right now,
robo wins at Glasgow and met with Robert [inaudible] Bishop of Glasgow.
We saw it was a friend and ally of his and grunted in absolution for the
killing.
We sought also made arrangements to have Robert crowns King six weeks later at
scone, the traditional coronation location of Scottish Kings.
The Bruce was crowned Robert the first King of Scots with all the usual pomp and
ceremony. And England's the news was met with outrage.
Edward believed that Robert had committed an egregious sin by murdering his
rival in a church.
And now he was compounding that sin by claiming a crown that Edward believed
belonged to him.
He called Robert and outlaw and sends an army North under command of his son,
the Prince of Wales to crush him.
The Prince was flying the dragon banner symbol that the usual rules of chivalry
did not apply. No prisoners were going to be taken.
And any enemies captured were going to be executed.
What had been the political conflict would now become very, very personal.
Robert did not yet heard that had been excommunicated by the poeple that King
Edward considered him an alcohol.
He raised an army of about 4,500 men and marched to Perth where an
English force about 3000 was Garrison commands.
It's by one of Edward's trusted left tenants,
the out of Pembroke Robert calls on Pembroke to come out of Perth and do battle
chivalric tradition,
but Pembroke claims that it was too late in the day and they would fight
tomorrow. So Robert's army made camp for the night,
about six miles away near the village of methane while the Bruce's army was
settling in for the night,
suddenly the English fell upon them in a surprise attack.
Sneak attacks and night fighting in general were not in keeping with the
chivalric code, but since the English claimed that Robert was an outlaw,
they didn't have to act Chavez towards him or any of his followers taken
completely by surprise.
The Scott stood no chance of the 4,500 that made up Robert Sarney,
at least 4,000 of them were either killed or taken captive, and then executed.
The Bruce was forced to flee with a small group of men having lost many of his
most loyal followers, more bad news followed the Prince of Wales captured,
killed Rummy counseling in September where Robert's daughter and sisters were
sheltering. The Britain said Robert's brother Neil,
the commander of the causal executed and took the women captive taking them to
England. Now, just before we continue with today's video,
do you want to take a moment to tell you about today's fantastic sponsor
blankets? Now, look, I know it's not always easy to sit down and read a book.
You know,
we all lead busy lives and I certainly find myself with less time to read than I
used to have, but the good news is I have the Blinkist app.
Now you can download this. And basically in here,
there are 15 minutes summaries of all of the best non-fiction books that
basically exist. There are over 3000 of them.
You can either read or listen to them. Me 90% of the time, I'm listening to her,
kind of just like a podcast or an audio book.
I find it easier to fit into my daylight.
That's kind of when I'm doing mindless things around the house,
or when I'm traveling to work,
there are 14 million active users currently using blinkers to get the best
insights and need to know info from thousands of books, self-help to business,
to health, whatever you're into it's on there.
They also have excellent curated lists where the blinker, steam,
and also guests to put together some specific recommendations,
like how to future proof yourself or just some of their favorite books.
And of course you can download them and listen to them offline.
The first a hundred people to go to blinkist.com forward slash biographics.
We'll get a week to try it out for free.
You also get 25% off if you want the full membership. Again, seven day trial
cancel@anytimeatblinkist.com for slash biographics and let's get back to it.
[Inaudible].
It's been a winter in hiding likely in the Hebrides islands off the Western
coast of Scotland. The year have been a disaster for him.
And he seemed to destined for obscurity as a leader of yet another failed
rebellion against English rule in Scotland. But even at this low point,
Robin was convinced of the righteousness of his cause the Bruce realized that
before he could take on the English again,
he needed to deal with the enemies in Scotland, the Cummins,
because most of his supporters were gone.
He couldn't hope to win and traditional battle.
Instead he would rely on hit and run tactics to loot and burn and destroy
support for his enemies from the civilian population in February, 1307,
Roberts forces came back to mainland Scotland. Initially things didn't go well.
There's one part of his army was destroyed.
And two more brothers Thomas and Alexander were killed.
Robert went to his family's ancestral lands,
a character raise man and supplies for his campaign.
The English went off to him with an army of 3000 commanded by Pembroke.
Who'd beaten the Bruce the year before,
but this time Robert was ready for him at Lou downhill on may the 10th,
the King traps Pembroke's army in a narrow Causeway,
surrounded by marshlands and killed hundreds of English Knights forcing the rest
of the army to retreating confusion with the English army subdued.
Robert could turn his attention to the Cummins. Meanwhile,
King Edward decided to go North himself and fight the Bruce.
But while traveling North, the King became ill with dysentery.
He died on July the seventh at the age of 68,
the Prince of Wales was now crowned King Edward. The second,
this was good news for Robert Edward. The, it was definitely not his father.
The younger Edward was not as intimidating. And more importantly,
it was not as interested in running the affairs of the state himself,
leaving the country in the care of subordinates,
particularly his favorite pairs, Galveston,
who is alleged to have been Edward's lover while the new King of England headed
South to consolidate his hold on power in England.
Robert headed to the North of Scotland where the Cummins,
their base of power over the course of the next 18 months,
he systematically crushed all internal opposition to his authority capturing and
destroying every stronghold.
The Cummins had burning and killing the inhabitants.
[Inaudible].
Now that the comings were defeated, the Scots rallied to the Bruce in droves.
It was time to take on the English, still occupied.
Most of the South of Scotland over the course of 10 years of war.
Robert had noticed a pattern in the English campaigns in Scotland.
They would invade in the spring and then they'd leave again in the winter
leaving causals relatively lightly garrisons do secure their foothold for the
next spring's campaign.
So he decided on a novel strategy for the time when the English armies invaded,
he refused to go out and find them melting his army into the Hills and engaging
in guerrilla style warfare though. It wasn't called that at the time.
Then when the English left and Lexi oceans hired going back out,
Robert came down from the Hills and attack their councils from 1309 to 1313.
Using this method,
he took one English fortress after another pushing the English systematically
out of the country without ever fighting them in open battle. In 13, 14,
the only major castle left and English hands in Scotland was Sterling and
Robin's brother Edward leaves each to it.
Robin now felt secure enough in his power that he issued a proclamation that any
noble in Scotland who hadn't yet acknowledged him as King of Scots would lose
their lands. In one year's time. Meanwhile,
the commander of the English Garrison at Sterling,
Phillip Melbray recognizing the hopelessness of his position,
made an agreement with Edward Bruce,
that unless he was relieved by June the 24th, he would surrender the castle.
If Sterling was lost, the English would lose and you control.
They had left in Scotland. So Edward,
the second's long distracted by squabbles with his own ability, decided to act.
He raised a massive army for the time,
15 to 20,000 men and headed North into Scotland to attempt to relieve Sterling.
Robert recognizing this, everything had done so far could be undone by this.
He knew he had to stop Edward before he reached Sterling.
He marched his army about half the size of the English to a position,
a few miles South of Sterling near the bannock burn,
fast flowing stream on June the 23rd,
the English arrived and advanced screen of cavalry came upon one of the Scottish
scriptural informations. They defensive darlings of pikeman.
That was the typical Scottish battle formation blocking the road to Sterling
King. Robert was with them rallying his troops one English night,
Henry to Bowen charged at the King and challenged him to single combat.
This was the kind of thing Robert, the Bruce relish. So in spite of the danger,
he accepted King Robert dodged a burns lawns and split the young Knight's head
open with his battle ax killing him instantly.
The only thing Robert would say about the fight later was that he was upset that
he had broken his favorite tax. The English cavalry commodity,
the olive Hereford had just witnessed his nephew being slain by the Scottish
King enraged.
He attacks the Scottish infantry unaware that had been led into a trap.
The grounds around the road had been dotted with pit traps covered by branches
so that when the English cavalry trying to spread out into an attack formation,
dozens of men and horses suddenly disappeared.
Falling into pits with wooden stakes planted the bottom.
Then the scripture information of the Scott's advanced killing.
Many of the tightly packed English horseman who had no room to maneuver Hereford
was forced to retreat. Meanwhile,
an attempt by another contingent of English cavalry to and circle the Scottish
position was opposed by the other part of Robert's army.
And the English were again compelled to retreat. The volunteers,
English heavy cavalry,
the Kings of the medieval battlefield had been defeated by peasant infantryman,
armed with Spears.
The English morale took a huge dip at the end of the first days,
battled a Scottish nights in the English army Alexander satin,
deserted to the sconce during the night and told Robert he should attack the
demoralized English. The next day,
June the 24th dawns and King Edward began forming his lines to charge the
Scottish position in the woods in front of him considerably more cautious than
the day before then to his surprise.
The Scottish infantry began emerging from the woods and marching towards the
English position across the open field.
It seemed suicidal than the arguments on the English side.
Wasn't whether it's a challenge to the sculpts or not,
but who would have the honor of leading the attack?
The isle of Gloucester who had been accused of calendars by King Edward for
suggesting the battle we postponed at one point was determined to win glory for
himself and charged accompanied. By many nights,
they ran right into the Scottish skill rung who instead of giving weight stood
fast and the cavalry was impaled on the long Pikes Gloucester.
And most of his contingence were dead within minutes.
Edwards now ordered a general advance English understanding of Scottish tactics
was that the children was a defensive formation and last it wasn't mobile.
When the troops started to March, the formation would break up,
but the Bruce had trained his infantry to use the shelter on as an offensive,
as well as a defensive formation. Once again,
when the English cavalry charged the scopes,
they were maps by a wall of Spears that stops their attack. Coles,
the English archers, you might've been able to break up.
The Scottish formations were ineffective.
The cavalry mounted on that toll charges were in the line of fire and the
archers have to stop after they started hitting their own men.
The Scottish infantry pushed the English back,
trapping them between the bannock burn on one side and the Pell stream on the
other. The cavalry had nowhere to maneuver and began to break ranks,
deciding that the battle was lost and would flat along with 500 roll bodyguards.
This triggered the collapse of the entire English army into a chaotic route.
It is estimated this over 10,000 English soldiers were killed during the battle
and the retreats back into England, fewer than 5,000 meters,
South of Scotland alive.
It was the greatest triumph in Scottish military history.
[Inaudible].
For the English Nobles. He captured a Bannockburn.
Robin negotiated the release of his wife, daughter and sisters.
After eight years of captivity,
Sterling castle quickly fell and all of Scotland's now belong to the Bruce.
Now the Scots were the ones conducting raids into Northern England's and even
mounted a serious invasion of islands,
which lasted for years before they were defeated in 1318.
The only thing Linds continued until 1327 when Edward the second was deposed by
his wife, Isabella and their 14 year old son was crowns Edward. The third,
Robert forced the issue by attacking Northern England and defeated the young
Edward at the battle of Stan hope park on August the fourth, 1327. Finally,
the English were forced to the bargaining table and Robert and Edward signed the
treaty of added Brown North Hampton in 1328.
The English formally recognized Robert,
the Bruce as King of Scotland's and renounced all claims of over Lordship to the
country, the war,
which had consumed Robert's entire adult life was finally over,
around the same time.
The Pope lifted the order of excommunication against Robert from over 20 years
before. But unfortunately for the Bruce,
he wasn't able to enjoy the peace for long.
A lifetime of campaigning had taken its toll on the King and he grew well in
1327 with an unknown illness, possibly leprosy or tuberculosis.
The illness blamed his life on June the seventh, 1329 at the age of 54,
his five-year son,
David succeeded him to the throne of Scotland and had a turbulent rain,
but it was his grandson, Robert the seconds, the son of the Bruce's daughter,
Marjorie who had the lasting impact on history. Robert,
the second was the first King of the house of stewards that would rule
Scotland's for over 300 years. Intel James,
the sixth of Scotland was also crowned King of England in 1603, 100 years later,
the two countries were formally joined together as the kingdom of great Britain
today, queen Elizabeth,
the second can trace her ancestry all the way back to Robert,
the Bruce who has had 19th great grandfather.
It is interesting to note that despite all of the English attempts to subjugate
Scotland's in the 13th and 14th centuries,
it ended up being a Scot that sat on the throne of England and unified the two
countries that way.
But we're sure that's just the way Robert the Bruce would have wanted it.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do at that thumbs up button below, don't forget to subscribe also.
Please do check it off. Fantastic sponsor Blinkist.
Link below. Thank you for watching.